bienvenidos al tercer vídeo de la serie
de ejercicios de aplicación del álgebra
relacionados con problemas de edades voy
a retomar donde nos quedamos en el vídeo
pasado pues si recuerdan me confundí al
final mientras ustedes están sentados
tranquilamente yo me pongo nervioso de
tener que explicarles resulta que si
obtuvimos la respuesta correcta si al
mando tiene 153 y raúl tiene 765 hace 85
años armando tenía 68 años y raúl tenía
680 lo cual cumple con que la edad de
raúl era diez veces la edad de armando
así es que nuestra respuesta fue
correcta y estamos listos para abordar
otro problema borramos aquí
muy bien
necesito teclear lo voy a teclear lo en
letra grande el problema dice juan
tiene cuatro veces
la edad de salman qué coincidencia este
salman aparece por todos los problemas
juan tiene cuatro veces la edad de
salman juan también es tres años mayor
salman
edad
tiene juan de hecho es un problema
directo no tenemos que ver con presente
y futuro sólo tenemos que ver con el
presente veamos cómo se resuelve
queremos encontrar la edad de juan así
es que asignemos a la variable j la edad
de juan no me gusta este marcador grueso
pero me voy a quedar con él nos dice
juan tiene cuatro veces la edad es alma
no no voy a cambiar por el plumón
delgado así es que si juan es jota
entonces esta primera oración vamos a
encerrar la en un cuadrado esta primera
oración juan tiene cuatro veces la edad
de salman podemos escribir la podemos
traducirla a una ecuación de la
siguiente manera la edad de sal es igual
a la edad de juan dividida entre cuatro
o también la podríamos escribir cómo no
vamos a dejarla así sal es igual a la
edad de juan dividido entre cuatro ahora
nos dicen que juan también es tres años
mayor que salman eso significa entonces
que la edad de sal es igual a la edad de
juan
la edad de juan
-3 la primera oración la edad de juan es
cuatro veces la edad de sal es esta
ecuación de aquí la edad de sal es la
edad de juan dividida entre cuatro y la
segunda oración juan es también tres
años mayor que salman significa que si
tienes la edad de juan y le restas tres
años obtienes la edad de sal bien ya
tenemos nuestra ecuación de hecho en vez
de haber escrito juan podía haber
escrito directamente jota así es que
hemos obtenido la ecuación jota sobre
cuatro es igual a jota menos 3
multiplicamos por 4 ambos lados de la
ecuación y obtenemos que jota es igual a
4 j menos 12 aplicamos la propiedad
distributiva y esto saltándonos algunos
pasos nos resulta en que tres jota es
igual a 12 para concluir que juan tiene
cuatro años de edad
si juan tiene cuatro años esta oración
que juan tiene cuatro veces la edad de
sal significa que sal tiene un año de
edad también dice que juan tiene tres
años más que salman nuestra respuesta es
consistente pues 4 es igual a 3 + 1
estamos en lo correcto la edad de juan
es exactamente cuatro años espero que
esto te sea útil diviértete ya has visto
varios problemas de aplicación
relacionados con las edades si aún te
parece confuso puedes volver a ver los
vídeos quizás ponerle pausa una vez que
el problema está escrito para ver si lo
puede resolver por tu cuenta recuerda
que tienes para entretenerte una gran
cantidad de problemas por resolver en
los diversos módulos que te ofrecemos
diviértete